Donald Trump's campaign basically stands
for almost nothing in terms of policy
and one of the few elements of his
campaign that we could even remotely
call a campaign proposal is his
completely asinine and half-baked
immigration plan and all of these terms
like proposal and policy and plan I'm
using these in the loosest sense of the
dictionary definitions of the words he
has this idea of rounding up 11 million
undocumented immigrants paying for what
it will cost to round them up paying to
deport them all building a wall with
Mexico that he says Mexico will pay for
Mexico will not pay for the wall we
would have to pay for the wall if that
were to happen and then letting people
back in if they meet certain
requirements of course other than the
rapists and criminals which from Trump's
hyperbole on this seems to be most of
the people that are trying to come in
from Mexico and point south it seems
that Donald Trump is now even
flip-flopping on that issue which is
insane to me because when you go to
Trump rallies and you ask people what
policy of trumps do you like most people
have no answer at all the few people
that do say well I like that he's gonna
get the illegals out and he's gonna
build a wall and even on that issue
Trump seems to now be softening and
saying possibly possibly he won't even
be doing the deportations let's start
first with a clip from CNN on Sunday
when one of his new there's been a
revolving door of campaign managers his
new campaign co-manager Kellyanne Conway
was asked he's still deporting people
right and she said that is now undecided
take a listen let me play something from
what mr. Trump has said previously
listen to what he said back in November
we do have a deportation force and
you're going to do it you mainly out of
their homes and a chow they're going
back where they came if they came from a
certain country they're going to be
brought back to that country that's the
way it's supposed to be so does Donald
Trump still support that a deportation
force removing the 11 million or so
undocumented immigrants what he supports
in fact his convention speech a month
ago Dana down and what he supports is to
make sure that we enforce the law that
we are respectful of
those Americans who are looking for
well-paying jobs and that we are fair
and humane for those who live among us
in this country and as the week's unfold
as the weeks unfold he will lay out the
specifics of that plan that he would
implement as president of the United
States will that plan include a
deportation force the kind that he just
you just heard in that sound byte and
that he talked about during the
Republican primaries to be determined
wait wait wait wait wait
everything now is negotiable it's to be
determined the guy who says that they're
all getting kicked out by force is
suddenly potentially changing that plan
because by the way most people realize
that the plan is completely impossible
and unaffordable so then of course after
Kellyanne Conway opens the door to this
the questions go to Donald Trump are you
flip-flopping on one of what I guess is
the three major campaign ideas ban
Muslims which he's already completely
changed his position on deport
immigrants and build a wall Trump
himself insisted yesterday I'm not
flip-flopping he went on Fox News last
night he said the first thing we're
going to do if and when I win is we're
going to get rid of all the bad ones
then adding that everybody else will go
through the existing process we have
which the Obama administration is using
and saying that that's what we're going
to do we're just going to enforce that
with a lot more energy does anybody
realize that of the few things the Trump
campaign stood for at some point this
was one of the major ones and even on
this Louis Trump is saying actually we
may just do what Obama's already been
doing just with higher levels of energy
what does this guy actually stand for
that would be different uh Trump knows
he can say whatever he wants but he
knows and his his staffers managers know
that he can't do whatever he wants ah
but still apart from this it's still
shocking to me that a year ago maybe
even more he was saying well I'm going
to outline my plan soon right
and he's still saying that now he's the
nominee and he's still saying well at
some point in the not-too-distant future
I'm actually gonna give you details
about my plans oh sure it's coming up
anytime as soon as he figures out
who the the best way to couch it to not
lose the nativist xenophobic vote that
he is coalesced and catalyzed another
example of this Jason is last week or
the week before Trump came up with the
brilliant idea of coordinating attacks
with Russia and other countries against
Isis which happens to be exactly what
President Obama has been doing on so
many issues he bashes Trump and he
Trump bashes Obama and he bashes Hillary
and then basically goes back to I'll
probably do what they're doing just
better and with more energy so the next
flip-flop the major flip-flop he's gonna
know it if he gets elected which isn't
gonna happen he's actually gonna change
the Democratic Party that's its next
flip-flop yeah he's gonna change the
Democratic Party from the inside as a
Republican you're convinced he won't win
I mean you're saying it much more I'm
saying 22 of 23 recent polls say he's
losing but you're actually saying he's
not going to be president and with one
poll foxnews gonna be yes it was like LA
Times USC or something like that that's
the one poll right now that says Trump
is ahead by one which really isn't being
ahead I mean it's the margin of error
yeah so anyway yet another one of the
mainstays of Trump's supposed campaign
platform which by the way is a joke
falls apart interesting we'll see how
the nativist xenophobes react to that